the craziest of fights Gojo vsukuna
continues and Gojo might be finished
because of the crazy twist in the end of
the chapter it's insane so make sure to
stay tuned for this absolutely crazy
chapter if you enjoy seeing these Jutsu
Kai's reviews on the channel one keep
them coming then curse technique laps
blow that like button until you see
fireworks you can also help us hit our
goal of hitting 2 million subscribers by
joining the special grade fam and
subscribing to the channel right now and
now without further Ado let's jump into
It spoilers and all so last chapter
ended off with Gojo realizing that the
wheel of maharaga needs to spin four
times until maharaga dabs the gojos
infinity there's three spins left and
Gojo constantly proclaimed that he
doesn't even need that much time to kill
sukuna and hilariously to our characters
it looked like he was so lost in the
fight that he completely forgot about
megumi's body which sukuna is now
controlling this current chapter though
chapter 232 starts with the wheel
spinning a second time already you you
might have thought they'd drag out these
spins for chapters but no this chapter
does end the spinning one way or another
as we'll see in other words we
definitely get the spinning climax so
now we got just two more spins left for
Gojo's Infinity to get adapted and
everyone screams for Gojo to hurry up
and that's good advice if you couldn't
finish sukuna before adaptation it'll be
hard to picture him doing it after the
adaptation still Gojo in the middle of
this is still like a kid in a candy
store smiling and having the time of his
life even though that won't last for
long as we'll see Gojo attacks by
wrapping his hands in cursed technique
blue he creates blue orbs all around
sukuna which move around destroying
everything this totally reminds me of
the sage of Six Paths true seeking balls
in Naruto it's a very creative use of
his technique and I love to see stuff
like that at this point creativity and
how they use their techniques is not
only interesting but it also May
determine the end result of the fight as
well but tsukuna isn't having much
trouble avoiding these orbs what Gojo
does well though is he uses them as a
extraction and then sneaks behind sukuna
while blocking sukuna's attacks
confidently he sends sukuna flying with
a kick this fight is so action-packed
that I gotta say it's gonna be one of
the most insane Shonen fights in anime
when it gets animated tsukuna looks in
pain and there is blood but the dude
sukuna is still smiling respect for that
and the wheel spins a third time already
a third time it's crazy honestly sukuna
looks like he's winning if you take into
account the wheel spin since Gojo's
attacks aren't even stressing him out so
far we now have only one last spin to go
and Gojo if he's gonna keep his word has
to finish off sukuna before that one
spin I gotta get props out of mangaka
for not dragging this out we're less
than half the way through this chapter
and we've already gone from one to three
spins out of four then as we've become
used to the characters continue to
speculate as to how exactly the
adaptation will work Yuji is the one to
ask how does the wheel adapt to a
technique does it adapt everything some
time or by taking the attacks twice
kusakabe is the one that says Gojo is
only used using curse technique blue so
far but says any option could be
possible so if it is a time thing it is
possible that since Gojo has been using
his Infinity techniques it's only a
matter of time for maharaga to adapt and
it could be possible that despite Gojo
holding back by only using blue so far
maharaga will still adapt to all of it
we'll have to wait and see exactly how
it works because we like these
characters are still speculating but
there are big implications for these
questions either way and depending on
how maharaga's adaptation works it could
well decide the fate of this match
that's how big of a deal it is Gojo
probably realizing he can't hold back at
this point anymore makes his move he
plans to take sukuna by surprise by
giving him the impression that he will
only use blue but he suddenly attacks at
Point Blank with cursed technique
reversal red however Gojo's red doesn't
deal much damage because sukune used
domain expansion in time and the wheel
turned Dark Again however as we'll see
the wheel turning dark doesn't reset the
count even if it might buy some time and
even though he wasn't destroyed by the
attack suguna for his part couldn't
fully neutralize red because it was
Limitless enhanced tsukuna then taunts
Gojo by saying and I quote being sloppy
and hesitating because your moves were
red end quote I love how this is like a
chess game where the two are continually
trying to out strategize each other but
props to sukuna he's not letting Gojo
get ahead of him and move so far and
again even with half of his face looking
destroyed sukuna is smiling it's an
interesting twist where even though he
is the one that's being defensive for
now he looks in control with his
confidence and the fact that time is
running out and Gojo just can't seem to
finish him off no matter what he tries
but what do you know Jujutsu Kaizen
loves its twists and turns I should say
as when sukuna looks confident and in
control he gets hit by a devastating
attack Gojo again used his powers in
creative ways and his red attack came
back after circling the building to land
a surprise attack on sukuna in a
devastating one at that you can really
feel the explosive power and pain in the
panel and things are only going to get
crazier and more insane as we reach the
end of this chapter but first a quick
shout out to the sponsor of today's
video the Subscribe button do you know
that the whole purpose of a subscribe
button is to be hit and millions of
subscribe buttons don't get hit a day so
if you want to do your part just hit
that subscribe button you're making the
Subscribe button happy you're making two
brothers who start in their parents
basement making YouTube videos happy and
now back to the crazy chapter finally
sukuna looks panicked and isn't just
smiling he knows this could be it Gojo
might actually keep his word and end him
before the wheel finishes turning Gojo
takes his chance and delivers a
devastating black flash punch to a now
defensive tsukuna making the already
injured tsukuna's eyes turn white
completely you know an anime this is
always a sign that someone's in heavy
pain and pretty much just could have
passed out not even Gojo is capable of
using black flash at will but he does
achieve it here and as we learned black
flash when pulled off greatly amplifies
the user's physical strike since we
learned recently how strong Gojo those
normal punches are making even the
strongest puke afterwards we can only
imagine how strong and devastating this
point-blank hit on a defenseless tsukuna
must have been it's not hard to believe
that after that combination of Blows the
fight could end here we see all the
bystanders watching and each one is
shocked in his own way the white-eyed
sukuna now appears knocked out in
maharaga's wheel Falls so it's all over
right but man Jutsu Kaizen loves its
twists as I said and just as it seems
over after Gojo even got lucky with a
black flash the wheel spins again even
though it's not above sukuna's head
anymore Gojo perhaps kept his promise to
beat tsukuna before the final spin but
that doesn't mean his fight is over
since now Gojo is trapped in the shadow
mahoraga starts coming out having
adapted to Gojo's Infinity Powers
everyone is shocked and in Terror as
they see this mahuraga delivers what
looks like a brutal slash to a no longer
smiling Gojo now we don't know how
severe this injury will will be after
all that Gojo accumulated against sukuna
but even if he heals it somehow he is
now exhausted and has to fight the most
powerful shikigami of the 10 Shadows
technique the one no user of the 10
Charles technique has ever been able to
tame in the past and we have yet to see
if maharaga will now have adapted to all
Limitless techniques or if Gojo can use
others to try to finish him off this may
well be the end for Gojo or at least put
him out of commission for some time
since as I said before the tension just
wouldn't be there if Gojo beats sukuna
now and the others can rely on a combat
ready Gojo to help them in the future so
my money is on Gojo at least being taken
out of commission temporarily after this
fight but let me know what you think in
the comments do you think Gojo will win
and if so how will the mangaka keep up
the intensity if that were to happen so
this fight against the strongest is
finally over or at least near its end
now but there are more crazy strong
characters in Jujutsu Kaizen ones that
even Gojo thinks can become as strong as
him so if that sounds interesting make
sure you don't miss our all special
grade sorcers and their powers explained
video link on screen right now don't
forget to smash that like button with no
mercy if you enjoyed the review And
subscribe and join the special grade fam
to help us reach 2 million subscribers
on YouTube I will be eternally grateful
if you could do that and I'll see you in
the next video fellow Space Cowboys